hi everyone this is Jonathan Johnson
today we got another opening trap for ya
so this one is the kinder trap also
known as the trap in the Budapest gambit
and this is a really cool one because
it's something that I've played before
in a rated game so I can tell you first
hand it does work so with that in mind
let's go ahead and take a look at the
board okay so in this trap it's gonna be
black as the one that's gonna end up
winning so we'll go ahead and look at
this from the black point of view this
occurs in the Budapest gambit which
occurs after d4 Knight f6 c4 and now the
move e5 and this is a very interesting
way for black to try to unbalance the
game from the very first couple moves
here and it's a good way to try to fight
for the initiative so white really
should accept this gambit there's
nothing else that should be seriously
considered and now that the knight is
under attack the knight can jump either
to e4 or g4 94 is the Pajero it's gambit
and it's a well it has a lot of tricks
and traps that we also could mention but
it is sort of a dubious opening which is
why most people prefer Knight to g4 and
if white does nothing to stop black
black just simply intends to take the e5
pawn back so let's say white decides
he's gonna defend his pawn bishop to f4
now the opening is gonna revolve around
how many times can black attack a5 and
will he be able to win his pawn back and
then get a decent game so Knight to c6
Knight to f3 again protecting the pawn
and now black wants to play Queen to e7
to attack the pawn again but he doesn't
want his put his queen in front of the
bishop so he inserts the move Bishop to
b4 check and now white needs to make a
decision with one of his knights here he
can play the move Knight to c3 which is
a very interesting way to play it does
allow black to double as pawns a lot of
the times but in most lines the Queen
will be able to go to d5 to protect upon
an additional time and it'll be really
tough for black to actually get his pawn
back but he will get a lots of
compensation in those lines but a lot of
players they like to play Knight B to d2
because this avoids ruining the pawn
structure and white is guaranteed to get
a slight edge out of this opening
because in the future he's gonna play a3
and if black is compelled at some point
to give up the bishop well white is just
gonna be a tiny bit
but all right it is blacks turn so Queen
to e7 and there's two main moves here
for white III and a3 and they're both
fine but if they play a3 black can play
a very tricky move that's caught a lot
of people off-guard including some
titled players so in this position
instead of worrying about his bishop he
can leave it in pre and he can take on
e5 now what needs to be really careful
he might be thinking oh he blundered his
Bishop but if you take it I hope you
guys can see what black would play here
I'll give you just a couple of seconds
to enjoy this music and see if you can
figure it out alright hopefully you guys
found it Knight to d3 smothered
checkmate so a fantastic way that has
caught a lot of people off-guard
not just in blitz but also in long
standard games so it's a very good trick
to have up your sleeve alright guys so
that does it today for the can injure
trap hopefully this is something that
you get to use in one of your games it
is a very exciting way to play so when
you get the budapest gambit the number
one thing you're thinking on your mind
is well how can I get this little trap
to work and the good news is even if it
doesn't work immediately it'll be
something that where you'll still be
playing a decent game without risking
any serious you know detrimental effect
to your position so attacked your Bishop
come on so you know it's something that
you might really want to play and this
guy's just dropping his pieces over here
so I hope you guys alright good move
well how embarrassing I just fell for
the trap so big thanks to Alex latina
you want to see more of this guy well
you better subscribe to our YouTube
channel we got more videos like this
coming out all the time